avos ni sienne sq la manoeuvre russe n'a
pas fonctionné comme prévu
plusieurs véhicules blindés sont
remorqués
un autre est encore au bord de cette
route l'une des voies d'accès principale
à la ville par lesquelles les soldats
russes ont décidé d'attaquer
vitaly a participé à la bataille on les
a tapé près du pont boom là-bas boom est
assez vite c'en était fini de leur
colonne l'ukraine était à nous est à
nous et sera nous ils n'ont rien à faire
ici
pendant trois jours les soldats russes
ont pris position dans les maisons du
quartier
ils ont même laissé leur reste je vais
vous montrer
ça c'est leur ration c'est écrit armées
russes
ramon était alors dans le sous sol de
son voisin une fois revenu chez lui il a
découvert que les russes n'était pas
parti les mains vides
il était chez moi ils ont bu manger ils
ont tout retourné les affaires des
enfants les miennes il devait chercher
de l'argent de l'or j'en sais rien en
tout cas ils ont volé mais antidouleur
mon parfum et de l'alcool ils ont pris
mes outils mais clé à molette la clé en
croix pour la voiture et tous les outils
électriques il y avait des affaires de
ses soldats rue j'ai tout jeté chapeau
tischer quand ils ont changé de
vêtements car les miens ont disparu mais
veste les plus chaudes ils doivent
encore les porter car ce n'est plus là
ces gens là méritent d'être tué comme
ils tuent nos enfants
son voisin de 80 on rumine encore
ils ont roulé pour se mettre dans la
cour la porte est cassé et là aussi je
n'aurais pas adressé la parole car je
n'ai rien à dire à ces gens là
à l'entrée de la ville sergei s'est
barricadé
je me sens mieux depuis qu'on a mis ses
sacs de sable j'ai construit ça dès les
premiers jours c'est important
la nuit il dort encore au sous sol de sa
maison le danger est toujours là
apparemment ils sont encore dans le coin
puisque il y a quelques jours plusieurs
soldats russes qui rôde et ont été
capturés par les nôtres dans le coin
[Musique]
c'est probable qu'il soit encore dans
les bois oui donc on ne sort jamais le
soir car c'est dangereux
c'est qu'ils peuvent s'introduire dans
les maisons pour chercher de la
nourriture et des vêtements aux
syndicats
ils réfléchissent à mettre sa femme et
ses enfants à l'abri à l'étranger
ici tous savent que l'armée russe
essayera de revenir alors vos initiales
ce que se tient prête
aux avant postes le maire de trente deux
jeunes entrepreneurs avant son élection
ils se forment désormais à la tactique
militaire
on a fait sauter les ponts mais on sait
que l'ennemi peut traverser la rivière
alors avec des entrepreneurs on a creusé
de ce côté de la rivière effet une digue
20 heures seulement avant que les mines
approche de la ville pour que les tanks
il est blindé ne passe pas
il s'en serait bien passé mais savent
ils présentent un intérêt stratégique
si mikko life au sud fait sauter ses
ponts il n'y a pas d'autres routes pour
aller au dessin ou à kiev la capitale
seulement par notre ville donc on se
prépare à revoir l'ennemi la deuxième
centrale nucléaire la plus puissante du
pays est également à 30 km
le maire s'est toutefois qu'il peut
compter sur un avantage décisif nous
n'avons aucun ennemi en ville
aujourd'hui nous n'avons plus aucune
disons vieilles querelles ou de
désaccord aujourd'hui nous sommes tous
main dans la main pour nous défendre ces
barricades que vous voyez ont été
construites en partie par mes adjoints
par des producteurs de lait
boulanger tout le monde s'y met
beaucoup de civils sont devenus
combattants
à l'image de ce patron de bistrot fier
de son café moulu maison et de son
engagement
il n'y a pas de plus grande motivation
que de défendre ce que vous aimez ce que
vous avez construit
les soldats russes eux ont une
motivation matérielle pour beaucoup il
s'engage et se bat pour l'argent donc
mentalement forcément ils sont plus
faibles que nous qui défendons notre
terre de damas
lui en a conscience il est toujours plus
facile de se battre
lorsque l'on sait pourquoi